and advice to heed keep your coats handy
because it is not over yet
taking a live look outside tonight still
cold still cloudy
snow now moving parum in indian springs
in that area where us 95 north is closed
because of a crash there's more chances
in the valley overnight into tuesday
morning
we do thank you for joining us on
channel 8 at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez we have team
coverage across the valley tonight of
course ted is in the studio tracking the
latest conditions for us
and madison kimbrough was on the strip
talking to tourists
we begin with orco mana for a look at
how things are in the west valley
tonight orco
well brian things were pretty calm for a
large part of the night here
but just within the last hour flurries
started yet again here in the far
west valley you might be able to see
some of it right now now this is video
that i
shot within the past hour and you can
see the snowflakes falling from the sky
this is in summerlin off of altar drive
right by the 215 and this comes after
the first round of snow we saw earlier
today now
this is video from this morning at the
vistas park near summerlin west
the snow was really coming down hard the
fresh powder
blanketing the ground in fact we saw
flurries across the west side of the
valley today
from down and mountains edge all the way
up to centennial hills and sky point
we got all this awesome video from our
viewers and while
that snow eventually melted those who
caught a glimpse of the white stuff say
they feel lucky it was very exciting you
know i'm
i'm local here i lived here for about
nine years and we've only had snow twice
so it was definitely exciting
i was not expecting snow at all today so
looking out my window was
really great to see now big flakes also
fell in the henderson and
anthem areas and this is viewer video
sent to us
showing the snowfall near anthem country
club
again the flurries started again here in
summerlin and the national weather
service
says that they've actually been getting
quite a few reports of
snowfall along the west side of the las
vegas valley
so of course if you are out on the
roadways be sure to take it slow
and stay safe because the conditions
could be slick out there
reporting live in summerlin tonight orca
mana 8 news now